foreign
with every walkout
[Applause]
in each part of the NHS
a warning that under the surface damage
is being done we've been pushed into a
corner that we did not want to be in
bite strikes further straining the
system Junior doctors like arjan
expected to vote for industrial action
insists is necessary
these patients three or four years ago
if we'd seen them would have treated
them that have gone home that have
experienced wedding anniversaries
birthdays grandchildren going up
Christmases now they're coming to a
hospital and it's the last thing they do
because there simply isn't enough of us
there and if they say that they want to
restore the NHS as they do then it
starts with restoring the wages of the
professionals that work in the NHS a new
survey of Junior doctors shows 7 in 10
say they always or frequently work in
understaffed rotors around half
described their desire to work in the
NHS in the next year as low or very low
7 in 10 also say they've worked in the
last three months despite not being well
enough
it's another emerging and unsurprising
picture of low NHS morale amid a wider
Staffing crisis with many health care
workers having moved abroad or
considering doing it for what they say
is better pay and conditions but on top
of that also concern over what impact
further strikes will begin to have on
the NHS backlog and its recovery
and so calls for more meaningful
negotiations that recovery in terms of
operations getting urgent Emergency Care
back on track that is jeopardized if we
continue to see these strikes unfold the
public needs to come to the NHS if you
have got a problem because otherwise
those issues get stored up in the
community
a government spokesperson said they're
open to talks stating we've been clear
that supporting and retaining the NHS
Workforce is one of our key priorities
and that includes Junior doctors their
pay will increase by a cumulative 8.2
percent by March 2023 as part of a
multi-year pay deal which also invested
an additional 90 million pounds to
provide the most experienced Junior
doctors with higher pay
[Applause]
the foreseeable looks to be strike
filled and this week the most disruptive
of NHS walkouts so far Adele Robinson
Sky News